I've returned from the motherland with a
tweed clad pipe smoking Queens saving
realization
Donald Trump is a traditionalist will
discuss the Disraeli esque high culture
conservatism of our reality TV president
then investor Hal Lambert joins to
discuss his new Republican only
investment fund with the stock ticker
symbol Magga finally Emily Butler and
his Eminence Paul Bois joined the panel
of deplorable z' to discuss sexual
assault allegations against Harvey
Weinstein and president Trump's huge IQ
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I don't know if you could tell but I'm
back from England I don't know if any of
that gave it away Mary the tweet or this
absolutely ridiculous pipe I was very
nice to spend some time in the
motherland I was in London and then
Oxford a stop by to see the son of the
supreme ruler of the multiverse Andrew
Klavan son and then I was up in the
Cotswolds in the countryside I'll have
one last puff before I put this out
delicious and I gave me an interesting
view on politics because I've been to
the UK before very briefly I'd never
really spent any time there and politics
is different there conservatism is
different there it even threw into light
some of what I couldn't quite understand
about Donald Trump the conservatism
there has something that very often
we're missing which is traditionalism
it's the sort of conservatism that comes
out of Edmund Burke who says the age of
chivalry is gone that of Sophos truce
economists and calculators has succeeded
it and the glory of Europe is
extinguished forever he's writing about
the French Revolution there and how
terrible it was even though he's
supported the American Revolution and
the trouble with American conservatism
is very often it is just the stuff of
softened sisters economists and
calculators all we really talk about are
how we want low taxes and you know small
government for its own sake and not
really the the reasons why we want those
things what what greater Goods those
things serve and it's very often
grounded in what would be rationalistic
ideas so Edmund Burke really doesn't
seem to have much care for rationalism
but that's the idea that we always just
stand for something it's just principles
floating out in the breeze but it isn't
founded on any real institutions like
civil society the church the family
local communities a lot of the reasons
why we prefer more local and smaller
government in the United States the
place where this difference is a
clearest between traditionalism and
those other varieties of conservatism
like libertarianism neoconservatism the
religious right whatever the place where
that is clearest is Oxford the
University of Oxford I didn't realize
this I went to Yale Yale is like the
Dizz
and version of Oxford Oxford is like the
real thing you know and Yale is Epcot
version of that it's a stunning place
and it has at it the weight of history
the difference between these politics is
really clear there and the difference
between the UK and the United States
there's no date that we can say this is
the founding of the University of Oxford
we know that there was teaching there
around 1096 but it's sort of sprung up a
little organically we developed over a
thousand years it's older than the
English language in its current form but
we know that Yale was founded in 1701
when I look at the various controversies
that have hit those two places in the
last few years I'm not surprised that
Oxford has weathered them better than
Yale so at Yale we had to rename Calhoun
College you remember that crazy
controversy students screaming at their
professors yelling at them professors
being fired for offending the little
snowflake II eighteen year olds who were
shrieking profanities at them they did
rename the college eventually at Oxford
there was a similar fit of hysteria
about Cecil Rhodes the statue of the guy
for whom the Rhodes Scholarship is named
because he was imperialist colonialist
and he dealt in Africa and all of that
it went nowhere it went nowhere they
totally let the statue stay because
there's a weight of something a weight
of history that describes the
conservatism of the United Kingdom and
describes that place that that we just
don't really have unfortunately in
American politics it's usually pretty
easy to nail down you know which
political party does which thing which
side and politics has which ideology in
Britain it's a little harder you can't
really tell us sometimes who are the
Conservatives you can't really tell who
are the is this liberal as this leftist
even where I was joking with Andrew
Klavan about this in in the England even
the socialist seems sort of conservative
they have eat you because as he says
whatever the British do if they're
living in the past so even if they're
socialists if they're communists
whatever they're there's just a certain
reading into their culture that they
can't seem to overcome even you know
even the socialism in England which is
very bad and not good for society even
that is better than the socialism in
Italy or France it just is a little more
orderly it's a little less lazy or what
have you now with Trump now with Trump
political ideology has become a little
murkier and a little less clear as well
over here there are questions is he a
populist is he a conservative is he a
secret Nazi Russian KGB Manchurian
Candidate all of the above perhaps from
my vantage last week in the motherland
perhaps the defining feature of
President Trump's political vision came
into view is respect for American
institutions and tradition his
traditionalism among all the calls to
topple Columbus statues and rename
Columbus Day Trump signed a proclamation
on Monday that said quote the permanent
arrival of Europeans to the Americas was
a transformative event that undeniably
and fundamentally changed the course of
human history and set the stage for the
development of our great nation
therefore on Columbus Day not indigenous
peoples take Columbus Day we honor the
skilled navigator and man of faith whose
courageous feet brought together
continents and has inspired countless
others to pursue their dreams and
convictions even in the face of extreme
doubt and tremendous adversity so it
this seems like a minor point the the
tradition of Columbus Day who were
honoring what day it is whatever but to
Trump it's quite important because it's
about respect and in a an understanding
and absorption a living through the
institutions that have made our country
great and not merely platitudes and and
simple words and phrases and ideas that
do it he's waiting vigorously on the
issue of NFL players not respecting
traditions like standing for the
national anthem and saluting the flag
even his economic policy of skepticism
toward big government and big business
alike of grand charitable gestures by
billionaires that look a lot like Donald
J Trump has echoes of the distributism
that was embraced by the 20th century
traditionalists like GK Chesterton and
TS Eliot among others speaking of Eliot
even Trump's constant use of highly
modern media like reality TV and Twitter
to propagate support for traditional
institutions reminds one of Eliot's use
of modernism - attack - attack modernism
rather and yes I think that is the first
time that Donald Trump has ever been
compared to TS Eliot president Trump's
take on patriotism might have been
written by Benjamin Disraeli the British
traditionalist and prime prime minister
who pioneered one nation conservatism
and one nation conservatism posits that
societies develop organically that
members within those societies have
obligations toward each other and it
emphasizes the pragmatism the reality
requires and insists the patriotic
devotion among other impulses compelled
a fortunate to take care of the less
fortunate when one part of America hurts
we all heard and when one citizen
suffers and injustice we all suffer
together loyalty to our nation demands
loyalty to one another love for America
requires love for all of its people when
we open our hearts to patriotism there
is no room for prejudice no place for
bigotry and no tolerance for hate make
America great again is a beautiful
phrase it's why Reagan used it in the
first place the make America great again
it's simple
the language is Saxon its Curt its
evocative it's called a populist appeal
by the common knowledge of the political
commentary at but what have they ever
known the phrase isn't actually that
populist the phrase isn't do whatever
you want in America the phrase isn't
make America work for you you you you me
me me the phrases make America great
again it's a call to make use of the
strong institutions inherited by this
country and developed in this country to
sustain the life of a country whose
organic growth has produced the most
just most charitable most free nation in
the history of the world
and speaking of Magha speaking of make
America great again we got to bring on
Hal Lambert we have the investor Hal
Lambert on today of point bridge cab
at all Hal has created an ETF an
exchange-traded fund for investing
exclusively in companies that back
Republicans its ticker symbol why it's
Magga of course Maga how thank you for
coming on thank you for having me
Michael so first question I guess this
is kind of a gimme but I gotta ask how
did you come up with the idea for a
Magga
ETF a Republican only ETF well you know
it sounds simple but it actually wasn't
it's never been done before so it
clearly wasn't too simple but I've been
in the investment business for about 20
years managing money I've been involved
in politics for the last decade I've
helped a couple different Republican
presidential campaigns was involved with
Ted Cruz's campaign
okay before that Governor Perry in fact
I ran a super PAC for Ted Cruz so very
involved in politics for a number of
years and being in the investment field
I noticed a lot of people were you know
upset about what's going on and they've
been boycotting products writing
services and and at the same time they
didn't realize that they actually owned
those products or services they owned
those companies in their mutual funds
and so they're boycotting out on the one
hand and then they're they're losing
money on the other right and you know
Starbucks is a perfect example a lot of
people are working or wake lighting
Starbucks the stock was going lower it
might have been losing money and not
realizing so I kind of started thinking
how do i how do i tap into that and
enable people to both you know with
their money and with their buying power
make big choices and there wasn't a
choice in the market there's there's
never been a politically based ETF
that's Annette Skye dia story that's an
interesting point too because I have
just considered it as a reaction to the
left constantly politicizing every
aspect of our culture every business
they're gonna do this they're gonna do
that but it also makes sense if you are
boycotting a business you probably don't
want to be owning it in your portfolio
you don't want to be hurting yourself
slapping your nose despite your face
do you worry that this ETF and maybe
others that will follow your example do
you worry that that will further
politicize the culture or is it an
appropriate response
culture that the left insists already on
politicizing now I think it's a very
appropriate response to the culture in
general and I think it's a good
investment decision as well so you know
you mentioned it being pro it is pro so
you're you're wanting to support
companies that are supportive of
Republican candidates and we may be
upset with Republicans and many of us
are but it's unfortunately it's a binary
choice right so you've got a democrat or
republican i do you want to be investing
with that's supporting the candidates
you want the ones that are supporting
heavily Democratic candidates or
Republican ones no that's that's that's
an option and that's the real question
too because someone like me who's
slightly to the right of Attila the Hun
I probably would take a lower return if
it meant that I got to slap Schultz
across the face or something but is
there going to be any conflict between
the returns you're getting and the and
your politics you know is it the case
they're Republicans supporting companies
actually are the ones that throw off the
great returns or are you or you
sacrificing a return to make a political
statement yeah I don't think you're
sacrificing return so what I did was I
took the S&P 500 and I screened it for
the political contributions of the PACs
and the employees of those companies and
I took the top 150 companies in the SP
so the SP is already a pretty exclusive
club you've got a great number of
companies um it's 150 stocks they're
heavily supported their great stocks
you've got a lot of defense companies
like General Dynamics Lockheed Boeing
you've got a lot of financials you know
there's some surprise companies in here
Goldman Sachs has always been thought of
as a big Democratic company well
actually in 2010 they switched and they
were they became a heavily Republican
supporting company so there's some very
good stocks in this portfolio I don't
think there's a sacrifice being you know
I did not realize that because I just
had it in my head that Goldman and a lot
of these a lot of major corporations
certainly a lot of Wall Streeters are
backing Democrats they back the
establishment so basically this fund
would be like Hobby Lobby or something
but you're you're saying actually a lot
of these companies that we think are
left-wing are trending toward Republican
donations correct you know you can watch
what they say or you can watch what
they're doing with their money and I'm
looking at what they're doing with their
dog
and they may come out and say one thing
but there they're doing something else
with their dollars and at the end of the
day money matters in politics and when
you're talking about lots and lots of
money this is a lot of money that's
being contributed it's affecting
election outcomes so now go ahead well
this is the you're absolutely right
there are a lot of election outcomes
that can be swayed by all of this but
the elections themselves the campaign's
themselves are even less clear in the
world of Donald Trump because we see him
sniping at bob Corker today little bob
Corker we see him fighting with
republicans fights very often that he
hasn't picked fights that they're
picking but will there be any
implications for the Magga fund if
there's a if there's a split if there's
a rift between the GOP and Donald Trump
will that be taken into account in the
in the fund itself I don't think I don't
think that it will affect things because
at the end of the day they're gonna have
to work with press and Trump and what
he's doing when he's talking about bob
Corker is hey this is a guy who's not
necessarily supportive of some of the
things that President Trump won on mmm
and so what you know what's interesting
about what president Trump's been able
to do is you know he's gone after the
NFL it's pretty interesting you think
about it this is the story's been going
on for over a year right yes pins been
pumping this by the way ESPN's owned by
Disney Disney's one of the top three
contributors the Democratic Party of
course I just kind of think about it
from that perspective but Trump's gone
after that what's happening in NFL well
everybody else was silent this is going
on for a year
finally he stood up and said you know
what we're not gonna put up with this
that part of what you said earlier in
your monologue I thought was great you
know we're different than England people
here the Republicans here a lot of times
need to be scared of the media and
Donald Trump's not scared of the media
and he's gonna go out and stand and say
what he thinks and a lot of the times
he's right he's saying what everybody
else is thinking and other people are
afraid to say and the best part is if
you go and you try to appease the media
and you try to get them to like you and
say I'm a conservative but I'm not that
kind of conservative I'm not that kind
of Republican that it's never enough
it's never enough for them and Donald
Trump has totally ignored that common
common sense the common conception that
we need to coddle up to the media and
he's won every time I don't think it's
ever blown up in his face no he's witty
and he's winning big in this battle
because at the end of the day you know
the American people are on his side
they're on the side of people standing
for the flag there for the side of
standing for the anthem absolutely and
people ought to be invested in companies
that are supportive of it I mean the
left is not for this left one is fine
with people sitting you know they're
fine with the athletes they want to come
out and talk about free speech that's
right free speech I mean they can't wear
a certain button on their on their on
their uniform where they can't wear
anything to honor the the victims and
the heroes of 9/11 but and that's all
fine but then when they're disrespecting
the flag then it's a matter of free
speech absolutely absurd well how I wish
you the best of luck I think I'd
probably would violate a thousand rules
and regulations by by speaking too much
about the fund itself but I do love the
I think it's a lot of a great idea and a
great way like Donald Trump who is
attacking the culture and he's a
cultural warrior I think it's a great
way to just keep pushing and pushing and
and bringing this fight on to their
level and into their field and and be
playing offense well I appreciate it and
people can find me on Twitter at at mega
index and as well they can go to invest
politically calm and look at what's on
the website so either one of those they
can learn about it but you can buy this
this etf's traded everywhere yeah anyone
that has a brokerage account can buy at
the tickers mega and just call up your
broker or if you trade online you can go
online and buy it and that's that's as
easy as that
excellent all right got to go follow Hal
on Twitter I know of course many of our
listeners are just survivalists up in
the hills of Montana who put every 100
percent of their portfolio into rations
and ammo for the apocalypse but you know
maybe consider diversifying your
portfolio how thank you for being here
I'm sure we'll have you back and talk
again thank you okay now we have to
bring on our panel of deplorable we have
an excellent panel of deplorable today
we have not only the birthday girl
herself Emily Butler
we have His Eminence is royal eminence
Paul Bois but I've got some bad news for
you I have to I hate to be the bearer of
bad news but if you are not a subscriber
to the daily wire you will not be able
to see them we can't talk about little
bob Corker together we won't be able to
talk about a Harvey Weinstein who's
accused of raping all of Hollywood and
and more unfortunately you can't do that
unless you go over to Daily wire calm
right now thank you to everyone who has
subscribed you help us keep the lights
on
you helped me afford three-piece tweed
suits just just for your amusement just
so that Marshall can have a little
chuckle all day so thank you very much
for that you'll get me you'll get the
intro Clavin show you'll get the men
Shapiro show you'll get no ads on the
website I know blah blah blah blah blah
wait a minute
here it is here talk about institutions
and traditions there is no tradition I
think that I cherish more than every
morning drinking delicious leftist tears
to give me strength like spinach for
Popeye and the only vessel that you
should ever use to to gulp down those
tasty tasty tears is the leftist years
tumblr it's made out of crushed up
little steven crowder a mug so it's it's
really been hardened and you wanted any
leaks
you can have your leftist here's hot
cold always salty and delicious go over
to daily wire calm right now and we will
be right back
all right on that point Emily I want
first your take on this political
investing idea
would you ever invest in companies or in
a fund strictly for their political
views well I think that question comes
down to two questions which is one can I
afford to do so and two what kind of a
political statement do I want to make so
on the first question probably not of
course we know Pamela deployables
doesn't pay that well not not so much no
so might have to pick up a second job or
two or three just to be able to put my
money into the stock market but you know
when facing with the kind of political
statement I want to make you know I I'm
kind of intrigued by it I think having
the ability to decide specifically
politically where your money is going I
mean we talked about actually putting
money into politics and things like that
like I think as mr. Lambert said
previously like all spending is
political when you turn on the TV and
you watch ESPN you hang money to Disney
which is paying money to Democrats like
every single choice we make influences
the money in our politics and I would
like to put my money behind
representatives I believe in companies
that believe in my representatives and
to be honest I'd really think that
people on the left the Hillary Clinton
supporters the Bernie Sanders supporters
probably don't even know enough about
money to be investing in the stock
market themselves they're socialists so
their money should come from the
government that's right well it just
comes from the sky it falls down from
the sky even though they also think
there's a limited amount of it and it's
a pie and the rich guy got that way by
stealing the poor guy they have a
complicated economics I've learned it's
true it's true right well yeah I agree
with that
mr. Bois is this similar to boycotting
shops that you don't like in stores that
you don't like should we put our money
where our political mouth is we run our
mouths all day should we put our money
there or should we invest in the most
liberal companies if they make money
very often they don't but assuming for
the hypothetical they do make money
should we just invest in them put our
money wherever we're gonna get the
return and then use all that money we
make to support right-wing candidates
when they run for office oh look I wish
we could just live in a culture right
now where we could put our money
wherever we want we could go to whatever
store we want we can invest wherever we
want
I mean I want that culture that's why
I'm in this fight but unfortunately
we're not in that culture we are in I
think what is rightly described as a
cold civil war where certain
institutions that have a lot of power
and a lot of money use that power and
use that money for very nefarious ends
and a lot of it is to curtail freedoms a
lot of it is to attack Christianity and
create an entirely new America where
none of those values have any place in
it so absolutely I fully support this
portfolio and I fully support using your
money in whatever way you can to support
conservatives and not give it to
liberals typical Paul Bois optimism
everything's always rosy to you isn't it
okay we have to move on to Harvey
Weinstein raping all of Hollywood The
New Yorker has published a bombshell
report they've they've said that three
women have accused Hollywood super
producer and Democrat mega donor of rape
there have been a ton of other women who
have accused him of sexual assault and
of sexual harassment including
celebrities including Mira Sorvino
Rosanna Arquette Bob wah you've lived in
Hollywood a long time do you believe
this report is it possible that such a
supe super Hollywood producer and
Democrat mega donor could really be a
dirty rotten lowlife as Harvey Weinstein
said Hollywood's the best moral compass
there's no there's no sexual harassment
in this industry come on I mean no in
all seriousness yes I do believe the
reports and I see no reason not to
believe it one thing that's a quite
striking is that all of them fit this
pattern it's always Harvey Weinstein he
invites some young good-looking actress
up into a soda
his staff is always there so they're
comfortable first and then he asked him
to leave and then once they're gone he
takes off his clothes and does something
really perverted and creepy so yes I
fully believed the report and I think
the man is getting his comeuppance and
his downfall is long overdue this should
have happened way back in the 1990's but
you know what it's it's very unfortunate
that it took this long get out this is
another reason why British
traditionalism gets it right these
three-piece suits are very difficult to
get off
they really restrain the baser impulses
of mankind
if I were RV when I couldn't I can
barely unbutton this if I'm looking in a
mirror and taking ten minutes it would
be a it's a profound statement and a
sartorial statement to say that perhaps
we ought to have some moral foundations
and traditional institutions to rein in
the debauched impulses of Hollywood's
elite Emily how did he get away with
this for so long you know Michael it's
it's a real puzzler it's a
head-scratcher and in an industry full
of dirtbags how one dirtbag just managed
just managed to get away you know I
think the bigger question is really how
at this point in his career did he
finally come crumbling down and that's
like that's an that's an aspect of it
I'd actually like to explore more you
know like Bill Cosby like how how these
people finally get brought down because
this is not isolated I mean you have to
be you're so powerful and you're at such
a level where Gweneth Paltrow is afraid
to speak out against you Angelina Jolie
all these other actresses who are
fearful for you know their careers
fearful for any sort of semblance of a
life that they've built already you know
in the brink of that span of time of
whatever Harvey Weinstein wants to do
with them or what Bill Cosby wants to do
with people it's it's a question to me
of how these things actually break and
how finally the truth gets out and how
the mighty actually toppled because this
is not again this is not isolated there
are hundreds of other people in this
industry just like him
and he's one of the biggest the baddest
the toughest the meanest like he is the
one who has the most accomplices who can
just shut everyone down and the bravery
that it takes to persevere in the face
of that I mean now the the writers of
the New York Times are getting slapped
with a lawsuit like we knew they would
and to have that that bravery to
confront that and say you know no we're
gonna push back on this because rape
sexual assault so many of these things
come down to a he-said she-said it's a
very ugly crime it's a very nasty crime
and it's also something that's very
incredibly difficult to prove it's very
difficult to prove I mean you can be
with somebody an entire night like I can
be with my husband we're having a great
evening
I we love each other like there's
nothing there that sets up and in that
moment between two people where some
person says no stop that and the other
person doesn't stop you know that's
something that really comes down to he
said or she said and especially when the
other person is the biggest guy in this
town for people who don't know who
Harvey Weinstein is he I mean perhaps
his influence is waning now clearly this
seems to be his downfall this guy was
the king I mean he was the biggest guy
out here obviously these women are
saying that he hurt their careers when
they were rebuffed his advances and it's
hard to see how that isn't true Sorvino
did clearly had a decline in her career
and for this town I've never mattered
enough in Hollywood to really see this
too closely or anything like that but a
number of my friends have had this
happen to them and I've heard the
stories and I've been at some parties
where where some shady-looking
characters are praying you know where
they're where they're speaking to young
girls and surrounding themselves with
young women it is it's not even an open
secret in this town it is the currency
of this town mr. Bois how did this guy
get found out how did he fall apart now
why now well I think the reason why now
is like you said his power really is on
the decline if this were five years ago
or 10 years ago I don't think this would
have come out I mean their report
right now circulating about how there
were photos taken by reporters in the
early 2000s of him putting another
reporter in a headlock and calling
another reporter the c-word and that
never got out because so many people in
Hollywood media were on his payroll
Hollywood Reporter a variety I mean they
would literally buy up articles written
by journalists and buy them up and you
know optioned the rights for them you
know they'd be having deals with Harvey
Weinstein about getting their article
turned into a movie or them writing a
screenplay so get this guy owned so much
of Hollywood and it just his power was
on the decline and I would not be
surprised this is of course more you
know my more conspiratorial leanings
well that's what you'd like to encourage
that on the show of course so please
yeah whatever bases you have I liken
this to I mean I don't know if anybody
out there is watching the show narcos
right now but I liken this to basically
like Sally cartel so the Cali cartel
taking out Pablo Escobar you know
someone one of his enemies in Hollywood
a power broker somewhere gave the green
light and it trickled down and now it's
winding up on the New York Times I
really find it hard to believe that this
was just you know - Wylie reporters and
they uncovered it and now the truth is
out there and he's getting his justice I
don't think so because like Emily said
there's so many people in this industry
he was too protected he was too pet
mm-hmm yeah who do this kind of garbage
and it's just coming out now because
somebody wanted to take him out and get
rid of him and clean up where he left
off and take his investors and take his
pipeline of influence that's what I
think well moving now to Washington DC
which is Hollywood for ugly people we
have to discuss this Donald Trump little
bob Corker spat he's back to bickering
with his fellow Republicans bob Corker
is the Republican nominee Republican
chairman of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee said he worries that Donald
Trump will start World War 3
Donald Trump responded with typical
trumpian subtlety and said that corker
begged for his endorsement and Trump
said no and that's why corker won't run
for re-election next time who
then said the white house is an adult
daycare center and someone didn't show
up for work today Trump then gave him a
lovely moniker little bob Corker and
like Lil Marco but with with two DS in
it little mr. bois Trump is being called
irresponsible and immature and reckless
here but is he the one who started all
these spats I mean look I never defend
Trump's rhetoric in these situations but
I always defend Trump's rhetoric but
we'll get to that later I'm sorry but in
all of these situations he's never
attacking innocent people like bob
Corker is stepping into the wrong here
and he's he's lambasted the president in
an interview with the New York Times
when he's on his way out it's just
cowardly and he's not even that
conservative in the first place so
honestly you know I never liked
president Trump's rhetoric but at the
same time bob Corker is not innocent and
he's walking into it and he should know
better that's true the rhetoric always
sounds a little harsh or a little
childish or whatever doesn't have the
the effect of a Reagan's speech or
Winston Churchill speech let's say to
put it diplomatically but what are we
defending bob Corker now I mean why this
guy has an F report card from
conservative review on his votes is a
senator should we really be defending
this guy or is Donald Trump the guy we
ought to be defending oh no we should be
defending Trump we we absolutely should
be on Trump's side at the end of the day
I mean look it's always it's a scale of
moral imperatives at right now I mean
yes it's not right that Trump is saying
this kind of thing is calling someone
little but the moral imperative right
now of preserving what we're trying to
do versus very an existential threat is
right now much more important than just
a personal feud between Trump and corker
and by corker giving ammunition like
that it it's harming it's it's damaging
and and the real thing is if Donald
Trump calling a liberal Republican
squishy senator by some childish name if
that's what's going to help us get
conservative agenda passed if it's gonna
help us get tax reform it's gonna help
us get whatever and that's up for debate
then do it man call him little maybe he
is a little guy Emily birthday girl
Butler would it be better for Trump to
refrain from using the nicknames or
isn't isn't that why we're here are you
not entertained is that not why you have
come I'm so pleased with season two
[Music]
season two of the gold house I tune in
nightly I mean it's just fantastic but I
you know I'm so torn on things like this
like I like Trump for his rhetoric I
voted for him because of his rhetoric
because people everywhere especially
people on the Left needed to see that
rhetoric wasn't going to topple a
country the way that everything was
going with Hillary Clinton the way that
she was talking the way that she's
echoed everything in her book which
still is just echoes that were tearing
this country apart and you can always
tell the people who are actually tearing
the country apart when they say that
this country will not be torn apart if
we unite against those evil 40 million
Americans yeah you know I mean it's it's
ridiculous like the things that he says
are ridiculous and I you know if I were
on his advisory board I'd say don't even
respond to this guy he's not worth it
he's not worth the time people didn't
know who he was before people don't care
you're only making yourself look
immature as we all know that he's doing
but when it comes down to it
there's nothing harmful that he's doing
it's pedantic it's childish there's
nothing harmful about this I don't
necessarily see where there's anything
helpful about this I don't necessarily
see where it's gonna get a conservative
agenda pushed through because he doesn't
really have the media on its side to go
like digging in through Bob corkers past
that's kind of what the conservative
media helps to do right so I don't is to
a you know Tillerson there's this rumor
that Tillerson called Donald Trump a
[ __ ]
the mainstream media that's every single
question they're asking what do you
think Tillerson called you a [ __ ] what
do you say and he answered with his
little joke and he said well I guess
we'll have to get the IQ tests out I
guess we'll have to do that he does
always hits him back
he's very off
making jokes and listen I compared him
to TS Eliot earlier in that show I do
not regret it at all I think he has a
similar traditionalism and they both use
very evocative language to defend
Western civilization there it is Donald
Trump TS Eliot
okay panel of deplorable z-- thank you
for being here Paul Bois the birthday
girl Emily Butler that's it that's my
show that's all I've got to say today
I've got jet lag I want to finish
smoking my pipe so I'm gonna get out of
here
come back tomorrow this is the Michael
Noel's show I am Michael Knowles
get your mailbag questions in and we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]